Good morning John; it's Friday, January 19th.
I was inspired by your little walk around
Manhattan in the morning, so I decided to
take a little walk around Missoula in the
morning. Turns out there's no one here! No
nannies and no rich kids, so I can't play
that game. I can play, like, picnic table,
park bench.
The park is completely abandoned, but it's
fun still! So you know this, but none of our
viewers do. Every year around this time, I
send a survey to all of my friends and family.
I wonder if all of you are getting nauseous?
That would be awesome!
My friends and family answer that survey,
and then I put it online so everyone can see
the answers.
My butt hurts. Jesus, this thing is not built
for my butt!
The problem is that the survey is text based,
so I can't actually send it to you, but there's
no way I'm going to break this tradition.
So this year, I'm going to give you the survey
in video blog form!
Questions one through six are the same as
they've always been, and I already know the
answer to all those questions, so I'm not
going to ask you.
We start with question seven: How long have
you known Hank and Katherine?
Question eight: What do you want from us?
Question nine: What are you doing? Please
be as specific as possible because we actually
all want to know.
Question ten: How much longer do you think
you'll be doing it?
Question eleven: Why are you doing it?
Question twelve: What do you want to be doing?
Question thirteen: What is next in your life?
Question fourteen: How you doin'?
Question fifteen: What's the best book you
read this year?
Question sixteen: Describe a perfect day.
Assuming that all things come to an end, how
will humans go extinct?
So how are you feeling about kids these days?
In this space, create your own question and
answer it.
Ambrozzo tastes better than any other kind
of food. What does ambrozzo taste like?
If you were a cliché, what cliché would
you be?
What's your least favorite part of any given
day?
Do you enjoy science fiction?
Cheese or chocolate?
What was your first concert?
Where would you live if you could live anywhere?
Would you rather invisibility or time travel?
If you could start a business that would be
instantly successful, what kind of business
would it be?
What's wrong with the world?
And the final question, number thirty: Can
I put this survey on my webpage?
I didn't get to play nanny nanny rich kid
this morning but there is another game that
I sometimes play. It's called, Go to Barnes
and Noble and see who's on the young adult
romance shelf.
(singing) Lady, lady, lady; lady, lady, lady,
lady, lady, lady, lady lady, John Green!
There's nothing wrong with that! That's great,
it's great! You-you're among giants; right
there in the middle. Tales of love and romance,
no, it's great! I think it's great. Really,
right there on the end cap, right in the middle.
Tales of love and romance. I think it's great.
Really, well done. And I'll see you on Monday.